le grand-père de yegor est décédé le 26
avril dernier à mario paul ville martyre
de l'ukraine un choc pour son petit fils
de 8 ans qui a choisi de raconter
l'horreur de la guerre dans un journal
intime
des mots mais aussi des dessins comme
ici ses chars russes
au fil des pages la même idée la mort
peut frapper à tout moment
ce sont deux voisines nadia et galia les
deux ont été enterrés la première
seraient mortes à bord écrit la deuxième
un peu plus tard c'est la dernière chose
qu'ils aient gora dessiné
pendant plusieurs semaines
lle gore sa soeur et sa mère ont été
contraints de vivre dans un bunker car
leur maison a été détruite par un
missile russe elle était situé près de
l'usiné opstal estime bruce ces quelques
images tournées aux téléphones portables
permettent de mieux se rendre compte du
calvaire subi par la famille atteinte au
plus profond de sa chair
je suis blessé dans le dos
ma peau est déchiré ma soeur à une
coupure à la tête et ma mère a les
muscles de la main déchiré
et aussi un trou dans la jambe
depuis quelques jours la famille de
yegor a trouvé refuge à zaporizhya à 100
km au nord de marioupol elle espère
désormais rejoindre la capitale kiev